what do you think it is in your history
as a human being that compels you to be
the kind of father I know exactly what
it is um my dad my dad was gone by the
really by the time I was eight seven so
my mom brought me up and I was really
not there all the time for the first boy
and then I got the opportunity to have
these other these other two kids and I
thought I can't I've now been given a
real gift to be the dad I I imagined I I
wanted to be or could be with the first
boy
Alfie and so um it was I've got really
I've got a chance to sort of repair this
and and switch it around and also I mean
I'm near I'm almost 27 years
sober
so which is
so that so everything I have today over
well really the last 20 years or so has
has has been really through sobriety
that's first
off but um the kids are now older I
think that what I'm most proud of is my
biggest accomplishment I think is
they're nice people
they really that's that's that's that's
the thing everybody wants their kid to
be so always brilliant and she's
wonderful and all the RO of it I I
didn't my my kids are not
Geniuses but they're really really nice
people I think in that more nice people
in the world we've got Geniuses they you
know we have enough of that you know put
we need really kind people kind kind
good good heart good heart healthy know
not mean-spirited and and I think they
saved my life yes me
[Music]
too